when people win their independence and
break away from their colonial overlords
they normally take their entire country
with them yet when ireland successfully
revolted against its inclusion within
the united kingdom it did not this chunk
in the north remains to this day a part
of the united kingdom despite it
previously being administratively a part
of ireland which raises a pretty obvious
question why didn't ireland take the
north with it why is ireland divided
well first of all we need to go back to
the 17th century this was when the
english and scottish thrones were held
by the same man james the first james
was also the king of ireland at least in
name and he wanted much greater control
over it his problem was that he was a
protestant king with catholic subjects
whom he felt were much more loyal to
rome than they were to him mostly
because they were as such he sees lands
in the north and gave them to protestant
settlers a process which over the
centuries changed the religious
demographics in the north and over those
centuries the protestants held much
greater rights within ireland than the
majority catholic population political
office was reserved for protestants
whereas catholics couldn't own land nor
could they practice their faith or speak
their own language without harassment in
the early 19th century british
leadership feared rebellion and so
passed numerous reform acts which gave
many of these rights back to catholics
as of the 1860s there were those in
ireland who pushed for what was called
home rule which meant that ireland would
remain in the uk but with autonomy over
the laws that governed it the british
said no and would continue to do so for
the next 60 years this position was
buoyed by those living in the north who
didn't see themselves as irish but as
british and so opposed anything that
could potentially separate ireland from
westminster in 1912 the pro-british
population living in the north called
unionists signed what was called the
ulster covenant this was a document
signed by half a million people and it
essentially threatened civil war if
ireland was given any autonomy world war
one gave both sides something else to
think about briefly but during the
conflict the easter rising broke out
this was a semi-spontaneous uprising
which wasn't popular amongst the irish
and was put down quickly and brutally by
the british the brutality of the
response as well as the quick and not
very professional execution of the
uprising leaders further galvanised the
irish people against british rule in
1918 elections were held in ireland in
which sinn fein a pro-independence party
won an overwhelming victory they created
an irish parliament and promptly
declared independence which meant war
long story short the irish won but
britain refused to give up the north due
to the wishes of the majority of the
people living there and also land as
such britain passed the government of
ireland act which split island into two
new parts of the united kingdom northern
ireland and southern ireland which was
by this point independent and so its
leaders didn't care what the british
parliament had to say about it northern
ireland was given these boundaries which
the british parliament chose because
they were reasonably the most that they
could keep whilst guaranteeing a
unionist majority there in mid-1921 both
sides agreed to a ceasefire whilst they
created a lasting peace and it was
decided that britain would recognize
irish independence on two conditions the
first was the island agreed to britain
keeping the north and second was the
island would retain the british monarchy
and irish leadership agreed to these
conditions although it splits in feign
and pushed ireland into a civil war the
pro-treaty side won and after that point
the island of ireland was divided
between the two nations and barring a
drunken offer from churchill reunion has
never come close to being a reality i
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching with a special thanks
to my patrons james bissonette kelly
moneymaker corso wolfe jerry lambton
jordan longley adam stalter y and hockey
captain cydog rod d martin marvin castle
spencer lightfoot gustav swan common
yoon boogery wiggly matthew shipley
marcus asner the mc wapper aaron the
white max and flaurio maggie paxkowski
corey turner alex schwinn anthony
beckett spinning three plates copper
tone words about books podcast winston k
wood charles the first ben evinson and
scottish trekkie